infectiously happy ahmed Rothman's big
grin and joyful dancing spread across
the world this week the little boy was
just eight months old when he was shot
during fighting between Afghan forces
and the Taliban my mum says a bullet hit
my leg that day and also hit me here I
didn't say anything but my mum and my
cousin were all like help she was crying
and saying help and look my daughter and
my son have been hurt the video was
posted by his physios that the
International Committee of the Red Cross
whose Orthopaedic Center in Kabul had
given the five-year-old a new prosthetic
leg that's pitch mop I must say even
after our walk this is the fourth leg
that we've given him he's working
independently and doesn't need other
people's help he's happy with how we've
treated him
[Music]
in this latest video Ackman's been
showing off his moves once again his
dancing better than ever and his smile
even bigger than before
doctors say because he lost his leg so
young the prosthetic feels natural for
him
but his happiness is bittersweet
hundreds of children just like Ahmed are
still being injured in Afghanistan
thanks to the people who are running
this hospital I'm happy I hope it keeps
doing well
I also hope our country won't have Wars
anymore I'd really like calm in
Afghanistan
doctors say Ahmed will be needing a new
prosthetic leg every year for the next
few years so he can keep dancing you
wanna shout it gets Caillou's